Heads up guys he's coming
around for his morning walk
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
godzilla vs kong ending and then credit scene
video there was an actual post credit scene that
they shot for the movie but they actually wound
up using the scene during a different part of the
film in a different context so we'll explain that
during the video and what's going on with sequels
where they leave the end of the film sort of
setting up where they're headed with the franchise
after this when they eventually do get around to
making new movies if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos and
obviously careful for spoilers for all of the
movie if you haven't seen it yet just because
we'll be talking about everything that happens
and everything they set up but just starting at
the end of the movie we'll talk about easter
eggs as we go through the ending and some of
the big plot twists that they introduce but at the
end of the film mechagodzilla essentially breaks
free from apex's control system and goes rogue
threatening to destroy the rest of hong kong
and then it's implied he'd destroy the rest of the
world so it's up to godzilla and kong to stop him
pretty much everybody guessed after the first
trailer was released and they introduced the
idea that godzilla had turned on man that it was
a big misdirect and godzilla was just going around
the world destroying all these different apex
bases just apex bases he wasn't destroying cities
just the bases because every time they activated
mechagodzilla to test his systems godzilla
detected it and went after it to trying to
destroy it the way they explained the new version
of mechagodzilla in the monsterverse movies is
a little bit different than the classic touhou
version of mechagodzilla which is more just like
a metal version of godzilla is the demon beshear's
character walter simmons is kind of like an evil
elon musk tech company owner who's developing all
these new advancements and cool tech products
to make the world a better place but secretly
since the events of the first new monsterverse
godzilla movie in the revelation the godzilla
the titans really did exist he used his company
in the new products that he kept rolling out all
the time as a way to develop mega godzilla's
systems over a long period of time so all this
time in the monsterverse timeline of movies when
monarch is doing its thing studying all the titans
like godzilla and kong all the other titans
simmons is building up apex the company is a
sort of anti-monarch with the goal of destroying
all the titans so that humans can become the new
apex life form on planet earth again that's the
reason why he names his company apex it's a very
bond villain thing to do he does come off in the
movie like an old school bond villain the whole
movie itself is actually pretty great for what
it is it's just this big movie about two giant
kaiju going at each other two big toho monsters
just beating the hell out of each other it's kind
of like going to watch a giant boxing match as
long as you go into the movie understanding that
you'll have a good time the weakest parts of the
film as you would expect are the human storyline
they introduce some really cool new mythology and
sci-fi concepts but some of the logic just doesn't
totally make sense but you have to have a little
bit of a human plot there just to prop up what's
happening with the titans like godzilla and kong
so i think over time they've learned to pull back
on the human storyline and all these movies and
just beef up all the titan storyline like we're
going to these movies to see the titans not to
see the humans so just in general godzilla vs kong
does a better job with that formula just tuning
the amounts of human stuff vs the titan stuff than
previous monsterverse movies but over this
long period of time in the monster verse
apex develops mechagodzilla and it's implied
they've been testing different beta versions of
his systems for years slowly perfecting him if you
remember during king of monsters they introduced
the idea that godzilla is traveling over the world
super fast because there are all these underground
tunnels that he uses underground waterways during
the movie apex actually has this visualization of
it so you see all these different pathways that
go through the earth's core through the hollow
earth which i'll explain in a second that's how
godzilla has been traveling around so fast it's
also implied that monarch and apex have started
to use these tunnels too because you actually
see some mechanical systems built in tunnels that
they're trying to use to access the hollow earth
so there's all this crazy infrastructure and all
these systems that it took trillions of dollars
and probably 20 30 40 years to build since the
events of kong skull island at least some of
the sillier parts of the movie are the hand waving
with the amount of money in how much time it took
to build some of this stuff like mechagodzilla
probably took trillions of dollars to build we
also learned that apex had been using other titans
that they had been artificially growing themselves
or cloning in order to test mechagodzilla but that
means that not only has apex been harvesting titan
dna and using it for their tech and product
enhancements using it to make more money
to fund the completion of mechagodzilla but
just in general they've been creating their
own titans themselves not just mecha titans
like mechagodzilla but actual biological titans
but that'll be important for future godzilla and
kong movies the idea that humans just in general
have started to create more titans like people
wonder is kong the only version of his species
that's left well technically they could clone more
kongs during the movie though simmons just calls
the skull crawlers here number 10. so let's imply
there are many other titans that they created for
this testing process make all the jurassic park
jurassic world jokes in the comments if they're
starting to create a bunch of titans but the big
twist to mechagodzilla is that he's actually more
like mecca ghidorah because they're actually using
what they described as an advanced ai algorithm
in combination with the low-level psychic powers
ghidorah possessed in his brains that allowed his
three heads to communicate with each other
and just for reference there actually was a
mecca ghidorah in the classic touhou films but it
looked very different like this is actually meant
to be mechagodzilla that's what they're calling
it but essentially they stole two of ghidorah's
heads and because his natural powers allowed the
heads to operate kind of like psychic master slave
control circuits they have dr sarah zalba's
son this character i think the idea is that
he's working for apex to get revenge on godzilla
for his father's death they don't really clarify
that during the movie but it's kind of there
in the background like you're like okay maybe
this is why he hates titan so much even though
his father loved godzilla and thought that all
titans were wonderful he's the chief technology
officer for apex and he's working as the pilot in
one of ghidorah's heads that's connected all their
control technology and systems back at their base
allowing him to basically pilot mechagodzilla
like a jaeger from the pacific rim movies
in fact legendary made this godzilla vs kong
movie they make the monster verse movies they also
made pacific rim so they're kind of borrowing or
ripping themselves off with this whole pacific rim
jaeger pilot situation which is basically what it
is he's kind of like a jaeger pilot and you have
the mechagodzilla robot itself running around
with the other ghidorah brain inside its head
with an advanced ai sort of giving it all these
commands but because it's such a massive creation
it requires crazy levels of power and that's what
they use this hollow earth plot for during the
film to find a fuel source that's powerful enough
to power up mechaghidora the way they want to
once they do find that out though it becomes so
powerful that it shorts out the psychic connection
between ghidorah's different brains and that's
what causes mechagodzilla to go on the rampage
what apex has done over time though to upgrade
him as much as possible is they built all kinds
of extra weaponry all over his body like they have
rocket boosters all over his body that help him
fly a little they allow him to move faster he's
more agile than regular godzilla and kong during
a fight he's got all kinds of missile launchers
all over his body his beam weapon is more like an
upgraded version of godzilla's atomic breath and
he's got a special drill built into his tail the
way they explain it though is that he's already
meant to be super powerful it's just that when he
gets the extra new energy source at the end of the
movie that takes him way beyond 100 power level
so that's how he's able to stomp the hell out of
godzilla and kong on their own when they're not
working together like he's supposed to be way more
powerful than godzilla and way more powerful than
kong on their own it's only when they team up at
the end of the film and tag team him that they're
able to defeat him and even then they're only able
to destroy him when godzilla recharges kong's new
axe with his atomic breath giving the weapon the
ability to slice through mechagodzilla like butter
it's almost like they're turning his axe into a
lightsaber by charging it up with his radioactive
material the way they explain kong's weapon
though is that it actually belonged to one of
his ancestors from many thousands of years ago and
it's kind of like a mudo bone combined with one of
the dorsal spikes from one of godzilla's ancestors
like they imply that their races have this ancient
rivalry that goes back tens of thousands of
years you know however long the titans go back in
history they're kind of fuzzy on the timeline they
just call it ancient times so you have to imagine
this tens of thousands maybe hundreds of thousands
of years ago even millions of years potentially
kong finds the weapon in the home of where his
ancestors used to live the sort of source of
this energy that they've been looking for inside
the hollow earth so the weapon itself is thousands
and thousands of years old but they confirmed
that it is the true birthplace of all titans on
earth including godzilla species even though it's
only kong we see going back there during the movie
the funny thing about godzilla during the
film is that once they activate kong's weapon
godzilla can sense the energy signature and
basically atomic breath blasts a hole straight
into the hollow earth so it's implied that if it's
that easy for godzilla to blast its way down there
then he could go back to the hollow earth anytime
he wanted to as well the whole energy source that
they keep talking about during the film doesn't
fully get explained but it's essentially this
vast source of clean energy emanating from the
center of the planet that basically is the source
of all life inside the hollow earth it's also
meant to be the source of all the titans massive
size and abilities like over millions of years
this energy source mutated all these species
until they evolved into titans they're not totally
clear on who created a lot of these structures
either because it looks like they were created by
humans or ancient humans who may have lived down
here at one point but there's a kong sized throne
there's a central chamber a temple that looks like
it was built by some ancient culture or maybe
it could have been kong's ancestors themselves
because they do reveal that kong is super smart on
the dl and he can communicate using sign language
and has been hiding all of his intelligence from
monarch this whole time just because he never
trusted them so if kong is this smart and present
day and he's still kind of a child so to speak
it's implied that his ancestors were probably just
this smart too like you wonder who created some of
these giant monuments built into the side of the
mountains in the hollow earth here like there's
the hand of a kong that's pointing just kind
of telling them where to go to get back to this
special temple maybe kong's ancestors carved
that into the side of the mountain this will
get into the whole idea of where they head with
the sequels as they start to explore more of the
hollow earth they just kind of tease the hollow
earth during this movie but after they tag team
mechagodzilla kong lands the killing blow with his
new weapon and then godzilla essentially gives him
the alpha titan version of a fist bump like hey
we're bros now we're cool and swims off back to
wherever his new home is now because they blew up
his original home during king of monsters if you
haven't watched the classic touhou monster movies
this ending scene is meant to be a reference to
the ending of the original touhou king kong vs
godzilla 1960's movie where at the end of that
film they kind of both go their separate ways
like peace we're out of here until the next movie
the actual end of the movie though this last scene
reveals that monarch has since taken kong back to
the hollow earth and they've created a new base
there to monitor him and they started studying
the rest of the hollow earth just in general
because this still is the first time anyone's
actually been able to travel there and survive the
way they explain that is that there's a special
magnetic field that covers the hollow earth sort
of protecting it but it's also there naturally
in the way they visualize it when you're traveling
through the barrier is it's meant to be this big
2001 space odyssey reference the evolution of man
scene at the end of that film when he becomes the
star child and inside the actual hollow earth
gravity is inverted like a dyson sphere so you
could actually potentially walk around the entire
circumference and when you travel through the
barrier there's this giant gravity inversion that
basically flattens you like a pancake and they
have to have these special apex ships that help
them survive that whatever dangers there were
before the events of this film they fixed that by
the scene so they can go back and forth between
the surface and the hollow earth as much as they
want to now this sort of canonized this is kong's
new home like he feels like he is home now because
it's his ancestral home and it feels a lot like
skull island the way they describe skull island in
the film too is that it's meant to be a version of
the hollow earth just on top of earth's surface
but they try to tease the idea that maybe some of
kong's species might also be down here because
it's massive and we've only begun to explore
it but they're not totally sure we only see the
warbats the kong kills some other giant bat titans
and a few other assorted smaller titans while
they're on their way to this special temple
but the whole idea is that there are many many
different other species of titans that are still
living down here so the whole idea with future
monster vs sequel movies is that whatever the
next movie winds up being most of us are probably
in agreement that the plot will probably entirely
revolve around what's going on with the hollow
earth in other classic titans coming back from the
touhou films via the hollow earth like they kept
teasing the idea of this ancient war of the titans
in the last couple of films even back in king of
monsters if you haven't seen those classic touhou
films there was a film called destroy all monsters
where they have this massive battle of the titans
so that would be like the new monsterverse
movies version of avengers infinity war and
avengers end game where you have just a giant war
of titans but in terms of the actual post-credits
scene that they filmed and the director said that
they just moved to a different part of the movie
i'm assuming that it was actually the scene of
them traveling through the hollow earth and you
get that 2001 space odyssey sequence and it almost
looks like you're teleporting across space-time
i think that was probably the scene that they
just shot for the actual end of the film but
then decided that they needed it earlier in the
film to explain how they go through this portal
and the thought is that the studio is just waiting
to see how godzilla vs kong does at the box office
and if it makes enough money or as much money as
they want then they'll green light the next big
sequel but everyone let me know in the comments
if you spotted any of the big easter eggs during
the end of the movie that i didn't mention in the
video and what do you want the next sequel to be
are you just hoping for them to do more with this
hollow earth plot that they set up during the film
i will do a full breakdown video the entire movie
that should post sometime in the next day or two
my full falcon and winter soldier episode 3 video
will post friday so if you haven't seen the film
and you watch this video for some reason please do
go watch it it is a lot of fun everyone click here
for all my godzilla vs kong videos and click here
for my brand new falcon and winter soldier episode
3 trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!